what is happening reject nation um Greg
who are you I know I'm gonna get
cancelled in this video
Olivia you've played how many assassin
you played a good amount of the aside
most of them right almost all of them
I'm working on origins now and then
obviously yeah and then I just showed
her the Valhalla cinematic trailer did
you like it yeah looks great now let's
watch the gameplay trailer together out
of the Ubisoft event and after this well
watch Far Cry six in a separate video
Greg is always aware a wooden caming
events are going on and is on top of it
forcing his girlfriend to be in a video
with him
because she is more familiar with the
games than I am I've been playing more
games lately I've seen thanks for the
credit I appreciate it
benefits of getting two TVs
[Music]
work in progress it's a work yes let's
not fully judge the game
you play as evil a Viking from Norway
games woke it's all you gotta say to
trigger so much
England is a Dark Age tangle of broken
kingdoms and warring dynasties and of
opportunity and riches as you prowling
this rivers by longship
you may relocations you slide from the
shoreline round your ship and blow your
horn to lead your reign include
nice
your crew will assist you in all your
ways so you burn it down and start but I
like Stephen cago too heavy for one set
oh I'm good at battering down doors
whatever riches and resources you
pillage may be used to develop your
settlement giving you access to useful
services better tools and you settlers
spend 10 hours yeah I know you
[Laughter]
we are guns nice
I was plowing through the crowd Wow
[Laughter]
enemies though but wearing a hood in the
grass - I almost forgot about the
stealth part of Assassin's Creed 4 oh no
oh no I'm sorry oh I'm so sorry I will
do it oh no oh he you really messed that
wall houses right
- law the more lenient secrets you
reveal
cool assault yes
got a beer party or into England the
enemy will push back in a series of
climactic moments Assassin's Creed
Valhalla was such a massive results in
which you divorce army into battle
against heavily
[Music]
keeping in mind that this is a work in
progress
I thought in the cinematic that was a
dude
oh I totally miss that mm-hmm they
showed the females they showed this dude
see okay and then they showed the female
too so I think you can choose if you
want to play as a female or a male
that's why the name is ambiguous
of course I'd always go with the male
you are ruining my gaming what is this
crap damn it oh it's next gen consoles
oh oh but just the Xbox one there yeah
in ps4 ps4 I could be playing all this
on the ps4 not an Xbox yeah exactly what
am i doing well from what I know about
Assassin's Creed this is starting to
feel like a completely different IP at
this point I don't know it just doesn't
quite mesh with em I'm gonna be honest
my familiarity with the Assassin's Creed
is me playing it for an hour and then
going alright I'll continue this some
other day and I just never get around to
it
so many Assassin's Creed games the main
thing that I found funny about this is
there's no like barely any stealth and I
associate so much of Assassin's period
with parkour and sneaking around I
didn't see any of that in here this is
just like brutal up in your face
savagery there's some of it you know
like if you have to go around town I'm
assuming if you were at a certain like
if you kill someone important then
you're wanted okay so that's what I'm
assuming the stealth is here that's why
you're here to correct me on these
things yeah well big part of Assassin's
Creed is stealth it's not a major thing
I mean what do you think about this
because it's like as an assassin's Creed
family I'm always hearing especially
lately with the games is that the
cinematic trailers are always so awesome
and then you play the game it's not as
rewarding as one might do yeah mi asuka
III assume who are all of the Assassin's
Creed
since creatures with my favorite game to
play because I could just go in and you
know I just like to attack man yeah yeah
yeah we're not patient I'm not patient I
bought a strategy and I've started
origins which the game controls are very
frustrating to me so it's been hard to
get through
you said odyssey's the latest one
Odyssey is the latest one but they do
play a little bit of that as well
once again the controls are strange so I
heard that they are changing it again
for this so hopefully they fine-tuned it
I just want it to be something I can
just go in and just eye one button for
one attack I mean another button for
shield you know I don't want to have to
knowing the way you play games it seems
more like you just go in there Jack a
whole bunch of people up in a village
I'm a lot more like let me calculate in
stealth and strategy I get really like
patient about it and I want to be as
efficient and yeah and you're more like
I'm gonna I don't think I've ever used I
don't think he uses shield in any game
but I feel like it's gonna be
interesting to see what Norse mythology
they bring into this we saw a little bit
with like the lightning how much is
going to play into the storyline here
because that's a big part of the Vikings
and who they were which to be quite
honest if you know anything about the
Vikings not many people but it'll be
cool to play as them yeah but they are
so glorified in television and games
that yeah they have the assault category
Valhalla did you guys like this trailer
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell keep a
lookout for a far cry 6 reaction going
up shortly last but not least
I want to use this time to shout out
homeboy Andrew Hayes who has recently
been dipping his toe back into gaming
and if there's anyone at our patreon who
could be a Viking it's this man right
here short stocky aggressive energy he's
the kind of guy who you might
underestimate due to his height but no
he's a brutal savage he wants to be
Wolverine one day and there's a reason
why I mean he doesn't have anything to
salsa he's cut all the violent but the
pillaging he's got down he's got the
pillaging down so love you Andrew hope
you've been safe during this interesting
time with a certain virus going around
the world be safe buddy yeah yeah I told
you not to go to that pool party the
other day